[Music]
all right and not to be outdone there is
a lot of right-wing cringe out there
and there's a new movie get ready for
mike there's a new red state
it's not called red state it's called
2025
is it called gray state it's it's well
okay great state red state was a kevin
smith movie red state right
yeah anyway this is the new gray state
look man i'm actually behind what
they're trying to do here but
for god sakes your production quality
this movie is called 2025.
life is different now we can't change
since 2025
the world as we have known in 2020 does
not exist anymore
the virus changed the world and
communism is all over the place
communism is all over the place they
didn't even write this out well
com i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry they wrote this like
it sounds like enrique tario wrote this
our intro has better production quality
communism is like all over the place or
whatever
a global world language developed
in four years a global world language
developed
also you don't have to say a global
world language you could say a world
language
or a global language oh yeah well mike
how you gonna do that when communism is
like all over the place or whatever
this is so badly written i'm i'm already
angry
communist is like all over the place or
whatever guys it's fine
things are illegal traveling is illegal
and christianity i can't do the most
travel
traveling's illegal like all right like
okay i get the vax thing yes the vax
passport but just
traveling and nobody can travel anywhere
yes
that seems like a dubious claim
i can't do the most important thing of
my life
oh my god he sounds like tommy rousseau
he's of course it's a foreign lisa
you're my future wife i did not hit her
it's [ __ ] i did not
oh hi biden we were going to have a
liter of beer
oh god here we go i can't do the most
important thing of my life
the most important thing in my life
cause communism is all over the place
man
to believe
[Music]
christian conspiracy
in a word document see attached
what what this looks like a high school
project right
yeah yeah but all these are grown adults
our great leaders created a system hold
on hold on
hold on i got it back up here
look at this take our great leaders
created a system our great leaders
created a system
they're using the mic that's built into
the [ __ ]
camera and it this whole thing is
amazing
somebody said directed by fox day
produced by vox day and starring
owen benjamin in association with big
bear productions
the united nations
yes i think that's defcon no that's laps
oh okay def con 3 would be in his car
crying about how difficult it is to be a
security officer
i was watching him last night oh yeah
he's got a lot of red flags in his
videos though
yeah somebody says roy's not gonna think
of this is the communist version of the
room
wow this is so bad to eliminate
this problem eliminate this is from
i won't give up the fight you probably
should honey
this this movie existing is the biggest
tragedy to come out of
um those murders in minneapolis
yeah you're right you're right speaking
of which
uh is the filmmaker also going to do
his family okay come on dude
i hope so it's a valid question uh
somebody else royce answered the
question okay
somebody showing jonah in the chat says
is this the gina carano's new movie from
daily wire
is this the one neither will i
neither will i oh hi doggie
the second i saw gina carano i knew she
was gonna be a star okay and i knew that
i wanted her to dominate me
i now live inside of her [ __ ] that is a
fact i have a home in here
and i have a mezuzah outside of one of
her labias and my life my wife lied
because [ __ ] do get wet
it's very wet in here her vagina looks
like a sarlacc pit
folks that's a star wars reference
i want to make a difference i want to
change
the world we're living in i know you're
tearing me apart communism
mike can you live in a world where
common communism's like everywhere bro
like yeah i do i currently live in one
okay cool
i have another question sure is mitch
going to be in the comments
in the in the documentary about when
this guy
family yes possibly
make jesus be glorified again make jesus
be glorified again
whoa
all right what are the wesley bros and
why well wait a second
doesn't this mean this movie already
came out
yeah watch the movie
wait what is this now amazon link a link
tree
that's a book no this is seven ways to
happy relationships
this is a book it's what it's like
scamming people where's the movie
where's the movie maybe it should click
their channel maybe they have an update
maybe oh you're right you're right
project delays you know
yeah that happens let's see here
um no just uh just another trailer
life is different now you can't change
that
i can't do the most important thing of
my life
to believe our great leaders
created a system the united nation
a world full of peace love and ice cream
i found the movie you found it
look at this [ __ ] bessie [ __ ]
comes in
comes in with the goddamn wing i like
that he comes in doesn't even
see just literally like a scientist that
just found a cure for something
bursts and goes i've got the movie i've
got
the world enslaved by a virus right yes
yes yes yes
i got it i got it here put it in show
links repest you're right bessie bursted
in the door
burst in the door just like i found the
movie
like like like we're in one of those
movies like outbreak
and he's the scientist that finally
figured out the cure
bursting into the lab like i've got it
it's a four gig file so if if we're
gonna riff it it has to be on one of
yours because my internet
is [ __ ] and like for some reason it's
fine
where is did you send it to me yeah i'm
giving it to you right now hold on
oh god
this is gonna be so good okay
holy [ __ ]
oh it's the whole movie
it's the whole movie it's on mega
upload they put the whole movie
on mega upload well someone did
so you should uh you know put it on
odyssey
i'm i i
cannot believe this so what time next
week
i don't know but i'll tell you what's
happening right now that it will be on
my hard drive in exactly 10 minutes
holy [ __ ] 2025 the world enslaved by a
virus
i guess they were planning for i guess
amazon or whatever didn't pick it up
right
and here we are i'm gonna see if i have
it on prime see if canada gets it on
prime they'll be really funny
ah it doesn't matter because it's gonna
be on my hard drive in 11 minutes fellas
i am [ __ ] so excited excited for one
i am
so [ __ ] excited this movie has to be
so good
holy [ __ ] i mean look at the second
trailer
i feel like again just using the mics in
the cameras
yeah but those are better now the
technology's better in like built-in no
they're not
no i'm pretty sure
merch is so [ __ ] angry because it's
like it's it's
it's like remember the old louis ck
thing when you watch paul o's movie
oh god that was great it's one of the
all-time best bits they ever did and
it's because
i i feel what louie's feeling in that
because the way he's just
expressing that frustration of like you
know you just didn't give a [ __ ]
and you threw this thing together and
said [ __ ] it right and you took
everybody's money
and you didn't like he was so angry and
i get that anger where you're like
so you didn't even care to uh like
dude look at it all right for instance
good example adonis paul right
adonis paul knows enough that you need a
boom mic
on a thing like that that he
purposely animates an errant [ __ ]
boom mic that pops in on his own show
as a joke like he took enough care
for the joke to animate a boom mic
you know what i mean like as a and these
people don't care they don't care nobody
cares
the news doesn't care tv don't care
anymore everything looks mixed horribly
everything looks and sounds like [ __ ]
now animation [ __ ] sucks
everything sucks